Lily Collins gives a health update on
her dad Phil who recently slipped and
suffered a serious head injury have you
spoken to your father your how's he
doing okay he's doing good thank you
et spoke with the actress at the New
York premiere of her new Netflix film
okhta where she stunned in Valentino
what do you love most about this what's
not to love I had to do a little shimmy
I guess my party dress it just got so
much going on I just loved it and it's
red my character's name is red no you
have to start mom how do you properly
pronounce the name of this movie okay ah
there's a lot of ways to say it but I
think once you see the movie the amount
of times we say it in the movie I think
everyone's gonna get it but it's okay
yeah we are animal lovers our plan is to
expose Miranda rescued Pope Joe bring
her back to you what's the special about
this film cuz we don't see too many of
films like this in the US we don't and I
think that's the nature of what director
bong does he brings things to light that
a lot of people will never see otherwise
and I think it deals with so many
different topics and subject matter from
environment to politics the food
industry nutrition love environment and
there's just so many things that he
deals with in such a beautiful way that
farmer growth is gonna destroy
[Music]
you